rené lévesque était incontestablement
une des figures politiques québécoises
les plus marquantes de notre époque et
pourtant le connaissons si bien en
faisant mes recherches rené van je
connaissais poche comme jugera pas tombé
en amour avec lui mais il me frappait
dans ses valeurs dans ce qu'ils étaient
j'ai trouvé ça incroyable fantassins le
scénariste marc tessier s'est entouré de
très jeunes illustrateurs pourra compter
en treize chapitres le destin
exceptionnel de rené lévesque j'essaie
de prendre les vraies paroles de rené
lévesque faire un espèce de collage
montage pour que ce soit lui que les
gens tendent pas moi le rené lévesque sa
lutte pour la nationalisation de
l'hydroélectricité au sein du
gouvernement lesage l'élection du pq en
1976 ou encore la nuit des longs
couteaux un artiste différent illustrent
chacun de ces chapitres de sa vie
y'avait façon aussi de présenter ce sous
un aspect documentaire puis le dessin en
fait
bon permet en fait j'ai l'impression de
rendre ce plu ben justement plus
dynamiques qui pluie avant de rajouter
un brin d'humour aux siens on va seul à
dire quelque chose comme un grand homme
raconte aussi des épisodes moins connus
comme lorsque en 1945 il a constaté
devises où l'horreur des camps de la
mort à dachau ou encore son passage à
radio canada marqué par la guerre de
corée la grève des réalisateurs de radio
canada où son émission phare point 2011
ex % de cette eau vers le québec sur le
mans mais je pense que point de mire
était là avant pour préparer le terrain
puis moi c'est quelque chose que
j'admire beaucoup cette espèce de
d'ouverture sur le monde tout en
construisant des bases solides pour une
société québécoise un éleveur qui
présentait avec ses qualités ses défauts
à l'intérieur de ceux de ce projet là
avec ses succès ses échecs également
donc ça nous fait également mon sens
prendre conscience de toute la fragilité
de cette hormone une invitation pour les
jeunes et moins jeunes réenchanter la
politique
si ça peut on permettre aux gens de
s'intéresser davantage à la politique
puisse se dire ah ben oui nos
politiciens peuvent travailler dans le
bon sens et pas c'est pas que du négatif
la bd quelque chose comme un grand homme
est un récit captivant qui nous permet
de nous remémorer un personnage
incontournable et tout un pan de notre
histoire ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]